[Music]
we're now a week into the russian
invasion of ukraine putin's forces have
taken swaths of land in the south of the
country but are struggling to get
control of ukraine's two biggest cities
including its capital kiev to talk
through exactly what's been happening
and why putin's invasion isn't going
quite according to his plan i'm joined
by dimitri alperovich a security expert
and chairman of the silverado policy
accelerator think tank in washington dc
and sir lawrence friedman one of
britain's top military strategy experts
and a professor at king's college london
who sat on the chilkot inquiry into the
iraq war
lawrence could you start by briefly
talking us through what's happened over
the past several days in ukraine and
what is the state of the russian
invasion at the moment
um
well
in its original form it stalled
uh and i would say in some respects
failed uh in that the aim was to move
quickly into
uh at least
kyiv and
kharkiv and
take the cities and
execute regime change and that just
doesn't happen
um i think it's taken a rather
unpleasant turn
because
because it's stool
um
and because of the difficulties of urban
warfare uh which are taking place and
it's not as if they've given up
completely on that
but they've the russians have resorted
um to much more brutal tactics
with
strikes into into the city centers um
this could be seen as softening up
um but i think it's
in a way also a sort of form of siege to
make life miserable
for the people there a couple with
shortages of um
food and medicines
i don't think
this will help russia in the end
i think the most important thing that's
happened over the last few days is the
mobilization of ukraine
that made what to me always seemed
likely
a hopeless prospect for for the russians
if they ever try to occupy and control
ukraine but that's made it even even
harder and so uh but it also means that
the war will go on longer
demetrius lawrence suggests there the
invasion isn't going according to
putin's plan he's increasingly turning
to more aggressive measures dropping
heavy artillery against citizen areas in
major ukrainian cities
what do you make of the change in his
plans
well what was most puzzling is that in
an initial four to five days of the
conflict they really did not fight like
they trained to fight um russian
military is a heavy artillery military
uh relying on on standoff weaponry uh
heavy weapons like
missile strikes and
multiple launch rocket systems uh to
accomplish the objectives they did not
use any of that in fact their even their
tactical bomber aviation was sitting on
russian airfields virtually completely
unused in those initial days because i
think they had
a completely mistaken assumption that
they could just roll into kiev uh with
uh you know a 10 column armored vehicle
um
reconnaissance
company and and take it over
that uh
turned out to be disastrous for them and
they've now reverted to the mean which
is uh leveling cities like they had done
in chechnya with grozny like they had
done in syrian aleppo we're seeing
indiscriminate targeting inaccurate
targeting into the centers of kharkiv
into the centers of kiev in other cities
um that is how they fight that is their
doctrine and uh unfortunately they're
not going to use overwhelming force and
kill a lot of civilians to accomplish
their objectives
lawrence will a bombardment of ukraine
similar to what we saw the russians do
to syria eight years ago and in grozny
and chechnya in 1999 actually work
um well i mean that they can execute
bombardments
it's much easier to to fire off
artillery from a distance than to uh
than to try to enter a city i i'm not
sure
it's harder to do i mean the point is
about aleppo say um
the aim was to depopulate aries to push
people out
and they had the syrian
infantry uh since doing the the work on
the ground for them
they haven't done anything like this for
in terms of ground operations for a long
time which is one reason why um they may
not have quite captured what they needed
to do and dimitri said but i don't think
just bombarding will work for them even
in graziani they still had to enter the
city and you can still fight amongst
rubble uh so it does it it it
it doesn't solve problems and you know
to the extent they're actually attacking
real targets rather than just
indiscriminate it really doesn't make a
lot of difference if you if you knock
out an administrative building
so it's not clear whether there's
a serious strategy behind this or it's
the sort of thing we do when when we
when we're frustrated and uh and we're
trying to work out how to move this
forward and we're sort of hoping that
the ukrainians uh might concede us a bit
in in the ceased fire talks so i'm not
quite sure if there's a clear end game
in mind with all of this at the moment
uh dimitri is there any chance that the
complete takeover of ukraine by russia
is now gone or is that still a very real
possibility
well they can certainly take it and by
the way they have made a lot of progress
in the south they took the city of
hersone which is a pretty big city
uh in in the last 24 hours they've
surrounded mariopol another huge city in
the south uh they're making progress
towards the north and zapporogie and
towards the nepro
so they're making progress their
offensive
is encountering much more resistance in
the northeast
where i think they expected a much
easier time given that it's mostly pro
russian-speaking population that they
assumed would be pro-russian
and of course from the west they they
are
in the key of suburbs uh fighting
finding there's pretty aggressive
fighting there um so uh i think it's
misleading to to to say that they
haven't made any progress um it's been
slower than they expected for sure and
they're taking more casualties
than they thought they would uh but
steadily but surely they're they're
taking progress and and they have the
forces to do so the big question of
course is what happens next you can take
the cities you can decimate ukrainian
military units with air strikes and
artillery
and then surround them with your ground
invasion forces but then what
and
as lawrence pointed out the the
ukrainian population is mobilizing i
know a lot of people um that are sort of
just regular people without any military
backing that are going off to fight
kissing their kids for the last time and
uh
uh you know getting a rifle um to go
fight the russians so this this can turn
into a very nasty insurgency for them it
seems like it already is
um and holding the country afterwards i
think is is going to be
an extraordinarily
challenging for them i mean i'd go
further i think it's impossible i just
don't think they've got the numbers to
hold a country i mean they're certainly
making progress in the south uh the
forces coming in from crimea
uh and they can push forward but you
know this is a very large country
and uh
you need you know if you just think of
the challenges that the russians faced
in afghanistan or even in chechnya that
the americans faced in iraq and
afghanistan if you have a serious
insurgency you need far more troops than
over a long period than they can really
spare for this so i think that in that
sense i think that
they would they will fail
um
the question is i suppose what
bargaining position they put themselves
into
as you uh on the assumption at some
point this there will have to be a
negotiated conclusion
lawrence we saw reports in the times
this week that some 400 mercenaries on
the orders of moscow were sent into kiev
to hunt down zelensky the ukrainian
president he has become a source of
inspiration for the ukrainian people and
frankly for many people throughout the
world but will he have to decide whether
or not to leave kiev at some point soon
well the the assumption to start with
was the americans were urging this
is he he needed to move out quite
sharply um
you know either go to levi's or to form
a government in exile even and he made
the decision to stay which i think
turned out to be the right decision in
terms of uh the resistance being posed
by by ukraine and it's interesting the
the the the qualities of leadership that
can be shown especially by somebody who
knows to find words and deliver them i
mean it does really help being an actor
in in in these circumstances and the
comparison with putin you know with his
long tables and
uh
scared of
human contact is
sort of wooden and odd phrases is quite
striking um
but the issue could arise i mean the
issue could certainly arise uh and you
presume they will have thought about
that but i mean he's not the only one
there's quite a number of senior
ukrainian politicians holed up
in kiev and at the moment they're saying
they'll stay
whether they'll
see that if russians genuinely are
pouring into the center
and there's a means of escape we don't
know i think the worst thing would be
for zielenski to be captured by the
russians i think that would be a very
bad turn of events
and dimitri to what extent is this
resistance making a big difference to
the outcome of the invasion that we've
seen so far
well i don't think unfortunately it will
make much of a difference to the russian
um
taking critical objectives uh like
potentially taking kiev it will slow
them down it will
cause them to take more casualties
unfortunately will also take them make
them to
be much more brutal in their tactics uh
you know you have to appreciate the the
psychological end of this cannot be
underestimated uh ukraine in particular
eastern ukraine and southern ukraine
looks a lot like russia
lots of people speak russian if you see
sort of a babushka on a street it looks
like the soldiers grandmother so
psychologically i think it's been very
difficult for the russians to fight this
war in the initial stages because
they've not been prepared in fact it
appears that most of the troops haven't
even been told that they're going to
invade ukraine until the very last
moment
there's been no realistic pre-tax they
don't understand why they're there
and why they're shooting at people that
look just like their family however i
think that's starting to change now as
they're taking severe casualties
inevitably that hardens people and
they're becoming much more ruthless
you've seen some horrible war crime
videos come out of them just shooting up
civilians um and again indiscriminate
targeting uh and and hitting um
universities hitting schools um
targeting hospitals
um so i think they're just gonna get
more and more brutal and again they can
take their objectives they did so
obviously in syria they did so in
chechnya
but
the question is can they hold them
and lawrence you were saying before that
you weren't convinced that russia could
actually stage a long-term occupation
is there any way that you think that
this invasion could still seem like a
success for putin
well um
i mean it it depends on the outcome uh i
don't think it won't achieve a success
in the sense there'll be a puppet regime
um because no no regime that isn't
backed by occupation forces will be seen
as legitimate and could cut remember
this is a country
that's twice seen moderately pro-russian
presidents overturned by popular
movements because they were believed to
be rigging elections so i don't think
um in that sense they they can succeed
uh
it's very difficult to judge what
success looks like i mean if if putin
really believes this is a country run by
drug addicts and nazis then you can say
well look there's no drug addicts and
nazis if you're saying that this is a
country that's trying to get nuclear
weapons say no one you know we won't get
nuclear weapons um so you you you can
the way that it's been phrased is a
special operation and so on makes it
actually hard to know how how you
present the result back back home
i think in practice
it's going to be difficult to have an
agreement that doesn't recognize
ukraine as an independent state
so what you're then talking about is
finding things that you can do
that seem to acknowledge um some of
russian's russian concerns perhaps
confirm the annexation of crimea and so
on i think a peace deal is possible but
it's actually quite difficult at the
moment
and it won't become easier just because
uh you you've er you you've caused you
committed more crimes and and
made the situation in
ukrainian cities more horrific in some
ways it becomes harder
dimitri what do you make of that
i completely agree i think uh the
atrocities that they're committing have
turned virtually all ukrainians except
those are still collaborating around the
pay of the
uh russians
into enemies for them and um i think
that hardened resolve uh will stay for a
very long time and uh it's gonna be very
very difficult for them to run an
occupation now having said that i don't
think we should underestimate russia's
counter-insurgency capabilities um if
you look at what they did in chechnya
with extreme brutality with torture with
war crimes they have
largely pacified their area we haven't
seen terrorist attacks in in chechnya in
a very long time and they've done it
actually rather quickly um they they
started the second chechen war in 1999
towards the later uh uh
of the year to the second part of the
year and um
largely completed their
counter-terrorism operations there by
about 2004-2005 so within five or six
years they've managed to pacify it and
uh there's just an incredible article
that i read back in 2015 where the
journalist was interviewing a chechen
jihadist in istanbul who was on the way
to syria that just highlights the the
the
russian victories in chechnya because
they were asking this person why are you
going to syria to fight the americans
and assad when you can be in chechnya
fighting the russians and he said it's
literally safer for me to be in syria
because in
chechnya you know you hold up in the
mountains you have to come down from the
mountains into the villages to get
supplies and everyone has mobile phones
they'll immediately call the russians on
you because they would fear that if they
don't and the russians ever find out
they'll massacre the whole village
that's how the russians fight
insurgencies extremely brutal committing
war crimes
but
they're able to achieve results in many
of these cases
obviously failed in afghanistan but did
work in chechnya
so
we'll see if they're going to resort to
these horrendous tactics in ukraine to
try to keep the population pacified i do
think that at this point putin must be
rethinking
his initial
assumptions about this this conflict
he really did i think i think that he
was going to be treated as liberator and
that the ukrainian forces would just
melt away and and go home
um
having seen the resistance that he's
encountering
and thinking about the long-term cost of
occupations here occupation here he may
be
thinking that he could pressure zelinski
perhaps with threat of death
to try to get some concessions i think
the minimum bar for him would be for
ukraine to recognize crimea as russian
for ukraine to forever abandon its
pursuit of nato and eu membership and
some sort of agreement on
demilitarization and a minimum no more
weapons supplies from from nato i don't
think zolansky would take that deal even
under threat of death but putin may be
trying to go for that
for that for that strategy
lawrence last question to you you wrote
this week it is now as likely that there
will be a regime change in moscow as in
kiev
what would a coup in moscow look like
oh i don't know i mean
all i mean i think as long as he isn't
captured and killed zelenski will in
effect be the president of ukraine for
some time to come now
whereas putin's position has been uh
challenged by this uh
i think you need to know
an awful lot more about what's going on
amongst the russian elite to be to be
sure i don't want i mean the russian
population as far as we can tell is is
broadly supported because what do they
know i mean they're told
on the russian media um
they don't hear the alternative voices
it's extraordinary how many brave people
have been who have spoken out but still
he said this isn't going to be a popular
movement i think it will be
worries amongst the russian elite
about the act the total isolation of
their country and the economic hurt
that's coming the sanctions are far more
severe than i expected i think most
people expected
i'm sure the russians expected
and though they've got a war chest it's
not all not all of that's doing them
much good at the moment so i think the
um the problems that putin faces
over the long term are are quite serious
it would be foolish to predict
um
that he he'll go tomorrow or
uh weeks or day or months or whatever i
just think his position uh is going to
be hard to recover for
from uh
what is this as you said a staggering
misjudgment that he's made
so
but we have to see
dimitri do you think a kremlin coup is a
possibility
look i think it's uh not very likely but
the chance of it is no longer zero if
you had asked me two three weeks ago uh
what is the likelihood that putin would
be ousted in in sort of a palace coup i
would tell you that it was zero
today it's no longer that and i think it
is precisely because the sanctions have
been so severe
and the diplomatic isolation which also
cannot be underestimated uh is rapidly
turning russia into a north korean type
of pariah state
so
when you look at the elites particularly
the the military and intel services
people that have enriched themselves
over decades that have through their
families bought properties and
yachts and and other luxuries in the
west and they're now realizing they're
in danger of losing it all and also
realizing most importantly that those
sanctions are not getting removed as
long as putin is in power no matter what
happens in ukraine even if
putin manages to achieve some sort of
rapid victory there
those sanctions are there to stay russia
will remain isolated economically and
diplomatically for years to come if this
man is still in power and i think it's
not out of the wrong possibility small
chance very small chance but not zero
that someone particularly in the
silvikey sort of hardliner movement
there we'll say the old man has made a
drastic mistake we've had enough it's
time for him to step aside
lawrence and dimitri thank you so much
for joining spectator tv
[Music]
you